- What if we have
15 or 20% inflation
by November or December?
We're talking about an alarming
problem where, you know,
the poor and working
class in our country
won't be able to afford the
routine staples of life.
But we're then talking also
about what happens
when it finally bursts.
And when it bursts usually
you have dramatic rises
in interest rates,
but you also have dramatically
high unemployment.
So I'm concerned about
the future of our country.
And I think we need to
get our house in order.
(upbeat music)
- I'm Dave Rubin and joining
me today is one of the senators
from the great
state of Kentucky.
Senator Rand Paul, welcome
back to the Rubin Report.
- Thanks for having me.
- All right.
So we crunched some numbers
before we had you on today.
I've got the papers right
in front of me here.
Now we just gave
Ukraine 40 billion.
According to my numbers,
we don't have 40 billion.
Am I correct?
- No, even before we
started, you know,
lavishing large sums
on the COVID bailout,
we were already about
a trillion dollar short
in our ordinary expenses.
So to pay for
Medicare, Medicaid,
food stamps, social
security, and the military
we're about a trillion
dollars short every year.
Now in the last two years,
we added an extra
4 or 5 trillion
just to really show people we
could spend money like crazy
but our normal expenses were
a trillion dollars short.
And so that's the
question I asked,
where does the 40
billion come from?
Who do you get it from?
Do you get it from,
do we borrow it from China
to send it to Ukraine?
Really, we borrow it from China,
we borrow it from England,
we borrow it from Japan,
but a lot of it we print.
And all the Republicans up here
seem to be concerned
about inflation
but they don't seem
to be concerned
about where they're
gonna find the 40 billion
they sent to Ukraine.
- Are you shocked
how few Republicans
decided to push
back against this?
I think what, it was 14
total, if I'm not mistaken.
- Yeah, it was a small
number in the Senate.
So, you know, it's about
20% of the Republicans,
about 10% of the Senate.
And over in the house, there
are about 57 Republicans.
But frankly, I look at the
list and I say, you know what?
I'm not really
gonna be supporting
or working for any people
who say that they are
for a constitutional
foreign policy
and yet are for shoveling
money out the door.
You know, we do have
problems at home.
I'm worried about us
becoming Venezuela, frankly.
destroying our currency.
And I see no,
everybody that looks at this
even the people who look at it
from the traditional central
banking point of view,
say we're so far
behind the curve.
They're not sure how
this is gonna end.
Because when interest
rates are still so low
and they've been so slow
to start increasing
the interest rates,
many people are predicting
there isn't going to be
a quick end inflation
that could get much worse.
What if we have 15
or 20% inflation by by
November or December?
We're talking about an alarming
problem where, you know,
the poor and working
class in our country
won't be able to afford the
routine staples of life.
But we're then talking also
about what happens
when it finally bursts.
And when it bursts
usually you have dramatic
rises in interest rates
but you also have dramatically
high unemployment.
So I'm concerned about
the future of our country.
And I think we need to
get our house in order.
- All right.
We're not very good at
getting our house in order.
We seem to wanna get other
people's houses in order.
And we don't do that
very well either.
This 40 billion though,
one of the things
that you brought up
in the last week or so was,
hey guys, how about we
get some receipts on this?
How about we find out
exactly where it's going,
what you're gonna
be spending in on,
who's getting the kickbacks,
et cetera, et cetera.
And pretty much nobody
has an answer for you.
Is that fair to say?
Or is that an overstatement?
- Well, there's something called
the special inspector general
of Afghanistan reconstruction.
He's been doing this
for several years now.
He has a whole team involved,
but Afghanistan, as you know
we decided the best
way to exit was to exit
in infamy and screw
the whole thing up,
but leave about 80 billion
worth of equipment there.
But this guy's an amazing,
he has an amazing team
at looking at the
waste and he at least
stops some of the criminality.
And I do mean
direct criminality.
There are thieves, there
are worldwide thieves
who suck up US tax payer
dollars and then they run.
One quick example.
They built a $90 million hotel,
or they got $90 million
for a hotel in Kabul.
They spent probably 10
million erected an edifice,
the basic outline of it.
And then the guy
took off somewhere
in the middle east and
took the rest of the money.
It still sits there.
It's just an empty edifice,
it didn't quite get built.
And so this kind of
stuff goes on and on.
And I thought this
guy would be perfect.
His name's John Sopko,
he's done a great job
at looking at Afghan waste
and catching the criminals.
Well, everybody came up to
me at first and they said,
oh it's a great idea,
Republicans and Democrats.
But then they got wind of
who it was going to be.
And so the Uber Hawks in
the Republican party said,
oh we hate him
because he's always embarrassing
us with all our follies.
As we go around the world
he finds where the
money's being stolen.
He's an embarrassment
to the Hawks.
And actually guess what?
There are Hawks in both parties.
So they both ganged up and
said, oh, no we can't do this.
We need to let Biden
pick his own person
which would be
starting from scratch
and would take six months to
a year, might never happen.
And they would probably
pick someone who's weak,
and will not do the job.
So it was a fight, but it shows
how much concern they have.
They do not have
concern for the money.
These people are not
fiscally conservative.
And really they wound up
just calling me names,
calling me an isolationist.
And it's like, well, no,
I'm a fiscal conservative
and they're not
fiscally conservative.
- No, I mean, you were
literally asking for receipts.
That's pretty much it.
In a more broad sense,
in terms of what's
going on in Ukraine,
I know we are
technically not at war
and we often now go to
wars without declaring war
and all of that,
and I know your stance
on that and I'm with you,
but are we at war at this point?
At what point when you
endlessly fund a war
are you actually at war?
- I think you're at war
when your enemy perceives
you at war and attacks you.
So there's a possibility
and we don't know this.
If everything goes well,
and the Ukrainians
keep fighting well
and they push the Russians
out and then the war ends
everybody will have said
it was all worthwhile.
But it's just like Finland
and Sweden joining NATO,
might be a good thing
if nobody attacks 'em
and that's defensive, but it
also might be a bad thing.
What if we decide that we're
going to locate nuclear weapons
in Finland for 50, 60 years,
they've said they don't
want nuclear weapons there.
You know, what if that's
part of being in NATO.
Part of being in NATO
is sort of accepting
the weapons that
US sends to you.
So I think we don't know
what if the provocation
does lead to a nuclear exchange.
You know, if a European
capital is bombed
or a US capital, or
large city is bombed
with nuclear weapons,
will people then look back
in retrospect and say,
well maybe we shouldn't
have pushed them so hard.
Maybe we shouldn't have insisted
that Ukraine be part of NATO.
And, you know, there
are many smart minds
who have written about this.
George Kennan is probably
one of the most famous
diplomats of the last century
said it was a mistake to
advance and to provoke Russia
with creating NATO
larger and larger.
So did Kissinger,
so have many others.
So did James Matlock,
who was the ambassador
under the first
George Bush to Russia.
So a lot of smart
people written on this,
but now if you say
anything, they say,
oh you're sympathizing
with Putin.
Even when I try to
preface every talk
by saying there's
no justification
for Putin's attack.
There's no sympathy
for Putin at all.
And that I hope
the Ukrainians win,
but it still doesn't
mean we should ignore
the fundamental causes of war
and try to at
least revisit this.
So we know how to prevent
war in the future.
I mean, even in the end
of the Ukrainians win,
there will be a
destroyed country.
Ukraine will be destroyed,
and then who's gonna
pay to rebuild Ukraine.
They're already talking
about us paying.
The 40 billion that we are
spending on the war effort now,
they're saying that'll
last till September.
They're gonna be back in
September asking for more money.
But the bill when we
go to rebuild Ukraine.
Russia destroys it
and they're going to
laugh all the way as we go
and spend a couple hundred
billion rebuilding Ukraine.
So yeah, we just
don't have the money.
We're outta money
for all the stuff we
promised the American people.
- Are you surprised that
some of your colleagues,
guys that I'm sure you
like, and that are smart
and decent human beings,
that they just don't get
the basic obvious stuff
that you just laid out there,
that they don't get once you
start throwing money at it,
you're gonna throw
more money at it
and it's gonna keep going,
and we've done this before
and we're gonna do it again?
- There's a disconnect
between the people.
And there's a disconnect
in particular between
the Republican primary
and the Republican party
voters and who they get.
They get a lot of people
who promise 'em many things
and then don't follow through.
Republicans at home and
the Rotary Club will say,
I'm fiscally conservative.
And they come up here and they
vote for all the spending.
They go to the Rotary Club
and says, I'm with you,
if you elect me, we will
get rid of Obamacare.
Seven Republicans in
the Senate came back
and voted to keep Obamacare.
We had the identical vote
under president Obama
when he vetoed it.
And every Republican
voted for it.
President Trump came in power
and said he would sign the law.
I introduced the
exact same legislation
as almost word
for word the same,
and seven Republicans who voted
to get rid of it under Obama
voted to keep foot under Trump
when we could have
gotten rid of Obamacare.
This is a problem.
It's a perpetual problem,
but that hawkishness, some
people define conservatism
as hawkishness, not
fiscal conservatism,
not balanced budgets.
They are conservative
only in the sense
that they are for
a bigger military,
and more might and that
we should spread freedom
around the world.
And these are the George
W. Bush Republicans.
And frankly, it's
one of the reasons
why I lean more towards
Trump on so much of this
is that he did have a good
head on his shoulders.
And he had a certain reticence
to get involved
around the world.
He wasn't afraid, he was
strong, but at the same time
he wasn't eager for the
beginnings of a world war.
And I think in some
ways he was like Reagan.
He actually thought, he
worried about a nuclear war
and did not want to be
the person who presided
over the destruction of the
world through nuclear war.
So he was not eager
to sort of, you know,
I think provoke war
around the world.
- I think I mentioned this
to you last time you were on
but your support for Trump
was one of the things
that finally got me to
support him because I thought,
all right, here's one of
the guys on the shortlist
of people I respect
in the Senate.
And he's, you know,
one of Trump's main
defenders right now.
So let's move to some
other stuff real quick.
This Ministry of Truth, that
seems to have collapsed.
You had a rather
extraordinary exchange
with HHS Secretary Mayorkas.
So I wanna play
just a little bit.
- Do you think
the Steele dossier
included Russian disinformation?
- Senator, that's not a question
that I'm equipped to answer-
- It was in the public news.
It was a, you may
have heard of it,
the Mueller investigation,
it was a $32 million
investigation
that went over a
couple of years.
Horowitz was an
investigator general,
and he looked at
the FBI's activity
in the beginning of this.
And what the FBI concluded
was that there were FBI agents
throughout this period
of time who concluded
that yes, the dossier was full
of Russian disinformation.
So let's say it is,
Russian disinformation.
You say your new
disinformation governance board
is going to help the
public with disinformation.
You claim it's not
gonna be about domestic.
It's gonna be about foreigners
and those evil Russians.
So here's my question.
The FBI concludes
that the steel dossier
was full of Russian
disinformation,
CNN propagated this
disinformation gladly
for years and years.
The difference, I guess,
between your opinion
and our opinion is that
as despicable as it is
that CNN propagated
this disinformation,
I wouldn't shut 'em down,
I wouldn't lecture 'em,
I wouldn't put it on
a government website
that CNN's wrong for
propagating disinformation.
The problem you have is
you're not willing to admit,
I mean, we can't even
have an agreement
on what the FBI said
was disinformation.
How do you propose that
you're going to have an office
of disinformation governance
if you see the problem
in even determining
what is disinformation?
- Oh, Senator, because
our work is not focused
on disinformation with large.
Where we, the Department
of Homeland Security
become involved is when
there's a connectivity
between disinformation
and threats
to the security of the Homeland.
Let me-
- Well, that's what
the Russians might
be considered that.
You mentioned the
Russians the other day
when you tried to pivot away
from this being
about censorship.
I think you've got no idea
what disinformation is
and I don't think the
government's capable of it.
Do you know who the greatest
propagator of disinformation
in the history of the world is?
The US government.
Are you familiar with McNamara?
The Pentagon papers?
Are you familiar
with George W. Bush
and the weapons of
mass destruction?
Are you familiar
with Iran-Contra?
I mean, think of all
the debates and disputes
we've had over the last
50 years in our country.
We work them out
by debating them.
We don't work them out
by the government
being the arbitrary.
I don't want your guardrails.
I want you to have
nothing to do with speech.
You think we can't
determine, you know,
speech by traffickers
as disinformation.
You think the American
people are so stupid
they need you to tell
them what the truth is.
You can't even admit
what the truth is
with the Steel dossier.
I don't trust government to
figure out what the truth is.
Government is largely
disseminating disinformation.
- So when I was playing that
before the show for my guys
we were all cracking up
because it's like this guy,
I mean, you cannot even agree
on what disinformation is.
That was your whole point there.
That none of this
makes any sense.
Beyond that, it's against the
First Amendment, let's say
- Yeah, the First Amendment
and constitutionality
doesn't work with
these people very well.
So I tried to get
him at least to admit
that he really didn't even agree
with the FBI on what
disinformation was.
We had the Christopher
Steele dossier.
The FBI now admits that it
was Russian disinformation.
In fact, Christopher Steel's
said he got the information
from a source in the Kremlin.
Yeah, I think it might
have been a source
giving him disinformation.
So anyway, I ask him about it.
I love the deflection.
He's like, well, you know,
I'm not an expert in that.
And I say, well, do
you read the newspaper?
We spent $30 million on it
and we spent countless hours
on television talking about it.
And everybody on your side said,
it was Russian collusion
that Trump colluded.
But it turns out that
was disinformation.
And I said, if
that's disinformation
are you gonna go to
CNN and shut down CNN?
Because for the last three years
they've been promoting
disinformation.
And I said, for the
record, I'm not for that.
- Right.
- I say, turn the channel.
If you don't like CNN.
And they're full of
disinformation, which they are,
turn the channel, but
I'm afraid of any kind
of government organization,
even one that would go
after the disinformation of CNN.
I don't want the
government anywhere
near determining what truth is.
It's not as easy as
a job as you think.
You hear facts on both sides.
It's like being a juror or a
journalist or even a scientist.
You hear a lot of the
facts on each side,
and then you try to
draw a conclusion,
but it's not always easy
and definable in something
that somebody from government
could be trusted with that job
- In all your years
in the Senate,
have you ever seen anything
that was more a direct assault
on the First Amendment
than the idea of this
proposed Ministry of Truth?
I mean, the idea that
the government would
somehow regulate
or punish or depress
certain speech?
- I'm worried about it,
'cause there are people
on the left and the right
sort of promoting this.
And I tell my audiences
all the time now back
at home because they're
really proud of me
on fighting the
Ministry of Truth.
But I said, look,
there's some on the right
who are setting up legislation
where there would
be government boards
because they hate
big tech so much
that they want
oversight of big tech.
And so we have to be very
worried about right or the left
getting involved with speech
and people need to remember
there are tons and
tons of choices.
Your podcast didn't
exist 20 years ago.
You know, when I was a
kid, you had three networks
you didn't really have
conservative radio.
You had ABC NBC and CBS.
The news was identical
and it was a very
subtle form of leftism.
It wasn't in your face,
but it was all liberal
but there were no other choices.
We've got all kinds of
choices on television now
on the right,.
We have conservative radio.
We dominate the radio sphere.
We have the podcast sphere.
So I don't worry about us
getting enough message out.
And I tell people
I'm kind of tired
of everybody that
complains about Twitter,
quit using it, go
somewhere else.
You know, I left YouTube.
I haven't yet left Twitter
but I left YouTube
and came to Rumble
because I don't
wanna support a group
that believes in censorship.
And if the others
continue to censor me,
I'll leave them too.
- Let me ask you
one other thing.
'Cause I know you're
limited on time.
I've come to the
conclusion at this point
that this administration
cannot be this inept
that all of the problems with
supply chain and inflation
and the bungling of Ukraine
and all of the stuff
this cannot be ineptitude.
This has to be intentional.
Am I being,
am I overstepping do
you think on that?
- Only if their
party is a death wish
'cause I think they're
gonna get steamrolled
in November because
of the inflation.
No, I think they
they really don't really
truly understand inflation.
Maybe they're dumb
enough to believe
that greed causes inflation,
but inflation comes from debt
and it comes from the federal
reserve buying the debt
and all that new demand,
all that new money that
flows into the system
bids prices up.
With gasoline,
they made it worse
by also restricting the supply.
So prices, supply and demand.
You reduce the supply,
increase the demand.
And boy, do you have
rip-roaring inflation?
But we've borrowed more money
in the last two years ever
even as a percentage of GDP
if you try to
quantify it that way,
more money than
we ever had before
and you even have
Democrat economists,
there was the firm and came out
in the last couple of days
on of Obama's economist
saying it was a mistake.
They juiced up the
economy too much.
And he said, I warned
him at the time.
So there are some
reasonable, rational
democratic economists,
maybe one or two.
But anyway, there's a
few of 'em out there
and they're even admitting
what a disaster this is.
So I don't think they
do it on purpose.
I think there is a high
degree of incompetence on this
and maybe they
just didn't believe
we haven't had inflation
since the '70s.
Maybe they thought
it just disappeared
and it wasn't coming back.
We've had inflation,
but we haven't had
this kind of inflation
since the late '70s
and maybe they thought
it wouldn't come.
Remember you had all
these people talking
about the new monetary theory.
- Yeah.
- And all this.
You can spend and
borrow as much.
I mean, Dick Cheney
was part of that too.
Deficits don't matter.
There are big
government Republicans
that have loved
deficits forever too.
But no, I don't think
it's intentional
but I do think
that it's enormous
and maybe bigger than
anybody has predicted.
I think it gets a lot
bigger even before November.
- Well, Senator I thank you
for being one of the reasonable
and rational people
we got in government.
It is a short list.
I appreciate your time.
Look forward to
talking to you soon.
- Thanks for having me.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics
watch our full episode
playlist, all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.